m'adresse à la gauche je suis socialiste
je le demeure mais j'aimerais que les
socialistes soient les pro-européens
beaucoup plus résolu beaucoup plus
conséquent beaucoup plus engagé je
m'adresse au président la république et
un européen je pense profondément que
c'est son adn et qui n'a pas fait de
fautes européenne mais j'aimerais qu'il
soit plus offensif si les aides
alimentaires diront qu'il manque un
petit peu d'allant il y à une prudence
que je connais qui tient aussi au fait
qu'il appartient à un parti politique
qui s'est divisée en 2005 qu'il connaît
les sentiments des français il n'a
encore une fois pas fait de faute il a
été actif sur la grèce il a une bonne
relation avec madame merkel il s'est
gardé ce que ne font pas quelques autres
même à gauche de toute forme d'agression
ou de petites phrases à l'égard des
institutions européennes il est
respectueux jamais la vision on attend
qu'elle soit plus fort que j'attends
quelqu'un trouve plus forte